Well, it is thrifty week on our show here,
and we love a theme.
And winning money is fun,
saving money is also incredibly important
and very gratifying.
It can also be very creative.
We challenged our good friend,
celebrity designer, Mikel Welch,
who is a Drew Crew member
and sustainable stylist Sarah Teresinsky.
And they did a little upcycling challenge.
Now, upcycling is all the rage.
I think we used to call it vintage shopping,
and now we're calling it upcycling.
Because we see the value in buying older things.
Not only are they more affordable,
but they can be better for our environment.
So we sent them to an incredible thrift store here
in New York to put their skills to the test.
I love this video. Take a look.
Hey Drew, we are here outside of City Opera Thrift Shop.
This shop is amazing.
They have been giving to the Opera community
here in New York city for well over 40 years.
Inside, they have everything from clothes,
decor, you name it.
I've got my friend right here, Sarah T,
and she is a sustainable stylist.
And we're gonna go head-to-head
and pick items that we're going to upcycle.
That's right. Are you ready?
Am I ready?
This is a serious challenge.
Girl, I was born ready.
This is all I do.
One,
two,
two and a half, you cheated, three.
No.
(Sarah laughs)
(adventurous music)
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
Think again, sister.
That's a pretty cool lamp.
I'm definitely into lamp upcycles
'cause there's so many things you can do with these,
especially older ones.
I like it but it just seems basic.
I've made all sorts of storage with books before.
(fun music)
I love taking beautiful pieces
and incorporating them into an upcycle.
I need more fabric, but this would be a beautiful ottoman.
Sarah, don't be over here, peeking at my stuff.
You stay back there.
Right back at you Mikel.
I need to find a jacket
that I can reupholster a ottoman with.
I mean, this has nothing to do with the challenge.
I'm sorry, Drew,
I just really want to throw this on
because I think it might be a good fit.
(fun music continues)
I'm thinking this one is a little more like masculine
and toned.
We have like straps here
or the strap fed in to here
where it's almost like a handle something.
I found this beautiful lamp
and I'm so excited to upcycle it.
So, I'm ready to check out, gonna head upstairs.
I am ready to check out, my friend.
All right.
Thank you so much.
You are so very welcome, thank you, you guys.
(fun music)
So how do you feel?
Oh, I feel amazing. How do you feel?
I'm just telling you now, I've got it in the bag
and yours needs to go in a trash bag.
Mine will come out of the trash
and look amazing when I'm done,
'cause that's what I do.
Well, we're gonna let Drew make the final decision.
So Drew, we'll see you back at the studio.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I cannot wait to weigh in,
because Mikel and Sarah are right here, live and in person.
Are you guys feeling pretty confident?
She's going down?
No, no way.
She's going down.
He's a big talker. He is not going down.
I love this!
I'm going to win.
Going down.
He's going down.
I'm not going down.
I'm sending her back to Texas.
These are the kind of fights I'm into
'cause they're healthy and not scary.
I'm in, and we're gonna find something creative
and I have to tell you,
we're gonna go to a quick commercial break,
stick around because I wanna see
what you guys did with the stuff.
So stick around 'cause we're gonna see what you did
when we come back, all right!
And we're back
(audience cheers and applauds)
with the incredibly talented designer Mikel Welch,
and part of the Drew Crew,
and his innovative challenger,
sustainable stylist, Sarah Teresinsky.
These pieces are incredible.
I'm really excited to hear from each of you about process,
so that we can all learn
and we're gonna start with Mikel.
Okay, so my process, honestly Drew,
was pretty, pretty simple.
So the basic thing here, I had an ottoman.
You can pick a old ottoman up at home,
at a thrift store, et cetera.
I found a big oversized coat.
Once I saw that it could cover the piece,
I moved on to accessories.
I found another coat that had beautiful buttons.
And then I found a cute little leather belt,
cut it in half and used that as little strap handles.
But I have one other little thing I want to show you too.
So we got the accessories done.
I wanted, just like an extra element,
because you know how you are,
you want things to be practical,
you want them to be functional,
and that's like really big with whatever I bring to you.
It's true. You know me so well.
So check out the front. So this was a coat.
I saved the little pocket
so that you can put your TV remote there.
(adience cheers and applauds)
(Sarah laughs)
It's not over yet, it's not over yet.
I'll tell you two reasons why I love this;
I can still tell that there is coat elements.
Yes.
Because of the buttons.
Yes absolutely.
I love the leather strap.
Certainly this tone of leather
against the black like herringbone.
Yes, absolutely.
So there's a lot of things working for me about this.
Glad you like it.
All right, Sarah.
Now, I want to see your before picture
so we can see the transition.
Okay, beautiful lamps.
Yeah, so a huge thing for me when I thrift
is I like to look for things that I see a lot.
You see a lot of lamps,
a lot of books, a lot of ties.
So I decided to gather them together
and create this fabulous little book situation.
So the great thing about lamps,
especially ones that are glass on the bottom
that are crystal, is that lamps screw apart.
You can screw the top, screw the bottom.
They come apart like an accordion.
And then I just took battery operated lights
and inserted them in the bottom, up into the lantern itself.
They come on and off.
And you can use the little
remote control, battery operated lights.
It's so simple to slide them back up.
You screw everything back on.
I used some of the pieces that were left over.
Obviously, I took the light bulb part, screws right off,
and then I went through
and I painted the bottom of this a little,
took a little bit of tie.
I see that.
'Cause that detail was not there before.
A little accent.
And the great thing about these
is that you can use them on your table,
you can hang 'em somewhere.
And then you just take your books
and you cover 'em, old-school with the ties,
like we did with paper books, right?
To give your books a little jazz up.
And then even, I mean, you got the remote control,
but Drew, how about
when you want to hide some stuff from your kids?
You just make a little pocket.
(adience member exclaims)
Uh-huh, You got the remote.
Do I need to walk around you?
(audience cheers and applauds)
What?
It is impressive.
I love the way that you tied in the fabric.
Because what I noticed about these lamps
was how these crystal balls played into this crystal ball.
Right.
So I thought they were tied together in that element,
but that was the one thing I was seeing between the two.
The fabric really brings the glue of the whole thing.
A fun little situation.
Both pieces are really unique.
And I think I might need a little help
from the audience to pick a winner
because I love you guys so much.
I'm just not up for the challenge
of ever dissing anything that you guys do.
All right, everybody let's make some noise for Mikel
if you're loving his style.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Mikel, it's a good one.
Okay.
Now, let's make some noise
if you prefer Sarah's creation.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Well, I mean.
(Drew laughs)
I'm just gonna go with you both win, all right?
I hereby crown you both
The Magic Miscellaneous Material Magicians.
And I want to thank you so much, Mikel and Sarah because
(adience cheers and applauds)
as much as I would love to take one of you down,
I think that there is really merit in both approaches.
They're very different.
It's not an apples to apples comparison.
There's something here for everyone.
And I just love you guys
and showing us and teaching us what's possible.
Well thank you for having us.
Thank you.
All right, Mikel, Sarah, thank you so much.
I love you both.
(bright music)